in Dubai King Charles focused on the
climate crisis but a boiling Royal
Scandal dating Back 2 years has
transfixed many around the globe The
Firestorm sparked by the Dutch version
of this book endgame by Omen scobby
readers for the first time saw two royal
names printed in connection with an
Infamous conversation about skin color
King Charles and Katherine Princess of
Wales in 2021 Megan Markle shocked Oprah
and the millions who watched the
interview when she revealed members of
the royal family discussed how dark
their unborn child's skin might be the
couple never revealed who was involved
in that alleged conversation and until
there is actual evidence of those
comments being made I will never believe
it but the British TV host Piers Morgan
named the Royals on his show Wednesday
saying if Dutch readers know Brit should
know as well he's a vocal critic of
Harry and Megan the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex this is what the author had to
say about the reported printing error on
itvs this morning in the UK I had never
submitted a book that had their names in
it who wrote or said what is not known
there is certainly a lot of talk about a
new book and an old Royal Scandal
Crystal ganing Global News London